[Music]
the African elephant population has been
decimated by poaching over the past 10
years if it continues this iconic animal
could be extinct within decades
elephants are killed for their ivory a
single tusk can fetch upwards of $4,000
on the black market
I think the realization has finally hit
home that if we don't stop this trade we
are in big trouble the slaughter is
disastrous
not just for elephants but for the
stability of African nations almost
every recent African conflict has been
fueled by money some ivory but it can be
stopped in 1989 in an attempt to save
the last African elephants the species
was awarded the highest level of
protection under the Convention on
International trade in endangered
species or sight ease this meant all
trade in elephant parts was prohibited
it was probably the most important
international legislation that has ever
been done for any wildlife because it
literally stop poaching across the
continent overnight the ban was so
successful that elephants were started
to really increase in numbers but the
site E's legislation included a clause
it stated that countries with
well-managed elephant populations could
downgrade their elephants to a lower
level of protection this allowed
regulated trade and sales of existing
ivory stockpiles that was the most
devastating change that could possibly
have been made because it opened the
doors for dual listing which has created
all the problems that we are seeing
right now one of the biggest sales of
stockpiled ivory was in 2008 when a
hundred and two tons were sold off
initially it was seen as good news for
the elephants because it raised fifteen
million dollars for local African
communities much of which was spent on
elephant conservation
but during the same period undercover
investigators reported a spike in ivory
sales on the black market operating for
over 30 years the environmental
investigation agency or AIA has used
undercover techniques to try to
penetrate wildlife trafficking gangs
they found the legal sell-off in 2008
revived the ivory market from our
investigations were actually engaged
with some of the trades we get the
impression that it was a feeling when
the illegal sale was allowed that
business was back it was okay to trade
ivory again the legal sell-off provided
the perfect cover for the illegal trade
because it's hard to tell if an
individual tusk is from a legal
stockpile or has been poached around 70%
of the world's ivory is destined for
China where its revered as a symbol of
wealth intricate carvings can fetch
hundreds of thousands of dollars
CIA investigators found that around 90%
of so-called legal ivory on sale in
China was from the black market but once
they make a seizure the EIA need
evidence that the tusks have been
illegally poached dr. Sam wasa has
developed a novel way to prove where
ivory tusks have come from using
elephant DNA my laboratory was one of
the first to develop ways to get DNA out
of elephant dung from elephants across
their entire range over Africa the dung
samples enabled dr. wasa to map the
location of individual elephant herds
DNA samples from seized tusks can be
cross-referenced with dr. wasas database
to see if there's a match we were
shocked to find that over the last
decade virtually a hundred percent of
those large seizures came from just two
places 78% of it was savanna
ivory starting from northern Mozambique
up through Tanzania into the southern
border of Kenya and you could see over
time how it slowly crept north the other
major hotspot was from a place called
the tridem and that was all forest
elephants using radiocarbon dating dr.
wasa and his team are able to determine
the age of the tusks so we took samples
from all of the large seizures that we
had and we did isotope analyses of each
of those seizures and we found that
virtually all of that ivory was new
ivory this research helps
conservationists know where to focus
their efforts
it also provides valuable evidence when
prosecuting ivory traffickers stamping
out the illegal trade is not just a
conservation issue the trade is run by
organized criminal networks and the
money funds militant and terrorist
groups the Lord's Resistance Army in
Uganda Boko Haram in Nigeria and
al-shabaab in Somalia have all been
funded by money from ivory but time
could be up on the illegal trade some
African countries are destroying their
stockpiles to prevent them from ever
being sold Kenya burned over a hundred
tons of ivory and that whole cascade of
events caused the price of ivory to drop
from about two thousand dollars a kilo
in 2013 to now around eight to seven
hundred dollars a kilo in July 2016
President Obama's near total ban on the
buying and selling of ivory in America
came into effect in December 2017 China
the world's biggest ivory market shut
down its domestic trade Hong Kong soon
followed suit Britain the world's
biggest exporter and legal ivory is
consulting on a total ban but is yet to
implement it closing the last legal
markets will stifle demand for ivory and
remove the cover the illegal trade
relies upon we can shut the ivory
markets down globally and domestically
so that we we eliminate the demand then
we have hope to save the elephant
you